genital herpes is a common type of
sexually transmitted disease or
infection it's more common in women than
men
the infection commonly affects your
genitals which are the reproductive
organs inside
and outside of your body
it can also affect your buttocks
anal area
or mouth
genital herpes is most often caused by
the herpes simplex virus type 2 or hsv2
while herpes simplex virus type 1 or
HSV-1 may cause genital herpes as well
it more commonly infects the lips
mouth
or gums
it causes painful blisters often
referred to as cold sores
this is called oral herpes
occasionally hsv2 can also cause oral
herpes
you can catch the herpes virus from an
infected person through close personal
contact during genital or oral sex
the virus can enter your body through a
breaking your skin or through the tissue
that lines many of your body cavities
including the tissue lining your mouth
and genitals
once inside the skin the virus can
multiply within your cells
this damages the cells that inflames
your skin causing painful sores as your
body tries to control the infection
as your skin begins to heal some viruses
enter branches of your nerve cells
called axons
the virus travels through the axons to
an area near your spinal cord where they
become dormant or inactive this is known
as the herpes latent stage
at a later time certain triggers can
make the virus active again such as
stress illness exposure to sunlight
and having your period
when this happens the virus can return
down your axons to your skin
causing another round of sores
the main risk for getting genital herpes
is having oral anal or vaginal sex with
a person who's infected
during vaginal sex there is a higher
risk of the virus passing from men to
women than from women to men
this may happen because the tissue in a
woman's vagina is more prone to small
tears enabling the virus to enter the
body
your risk of infection also goes up as
the number of sex partners you have
increases
if you have this human immunodeficiency
virus or HIV you have an increased risk
of getting genital herpes
many people never have symptoms and
there are no symptoms during latent
stages
but symptoms of an active infection in
women include painful sores or blisters
in the genital area
common sites include the genitals on the
outside of your body also known as the
vulva
the vagina
cervix
anus
thighs
and buttocks
in men the common sites of sores or
blisters include the penis
scrotum
anus
thighs
and buttocks
in both men and women sores may also be
found on the lips
tongue
gums
eyes
and fingers
other symptoms include pain for
difficult urination
feeling unwell or having flu-like
symptoms and swollen lymph nodes in the
groin
in people with a weakened immune system
such as those with HIV genital sores can
be severe and long lasting
if your immune system is weak the herpes
virus may also spread to other parts of
your body such as the brain and spinal
cord
eyes
esophagus
lungs
and liver
and during vaginal childbirth women can
also pass the herpes virus to their
newborn baby if they become infected or
have a secondary outbreak near their
delivery date
there's no cure for genital herpes
once infected your body will always
Harbor the virus
people who aren't sexually active and
rarely or never have symptoms may not
need any treatment
but your health care provider can
prescribe an antiviral medication to
prevent or reduce symptoms such as
acyclovir or valacyclovir if you only
have a few outbreaks a year you may only
need antiviral medication during each
outbreak this is called episodic therapy
if you have many outbreaks a year or if
you're sexually active you may take
antiviral medication daily this is
called suppressive therapy
it can prevent outbreaks
reduce how many outbreaks you have
reduce how long outbreaks last
and reduce the risk of passing genital
herpes to a sex partner
if you have genital herpes taking
antiviral medication and using latex
condoms during sex can help prevent it
spread to others
to find out more about genital herpes
talk to your health care provider